cerca de un centenar de misiles
rompieron la aparente calma que reinaba
en territorio ucraniano Rusia
contraatacó días después de que las
fuerzas de kiev recuperaran la región de
gerson selensky advirtió que los
bombardeos podrían continuar una decena
de ciudades fueron tocadas por lo que
Ucrania denominó como la mayor ola de
ataques desde que se desató la guerra
se lanzaron 85 ataques con misiles
contra Ucrania contra nuestras ciudades
principalmente en la infraestructura
energética está claro lo que quiere el
enemigo no logrará su objetivo
estamos trabajando restauraremos todo
sobreviviremos a todo Gloria a Ucrania
lo estás haciendo muy bien
Jeff sufrió los efectos de los
bombardeos que chocaron contra
apartamentos residenciales
sentí la explosión luego vi el humo
corría al balcón para verte de donde
venía el humo al principio Pensé que
podría ser una explosión de gas y
entrada la noche la oscuridad se apoderó
de nuevo de las calles de la capital
debido a cortes de energía por la
infraestructura eléctrica afectada
creemos que nadie debería hacer esto
especialmente nuestros vecinos esperemos
que ganemos Gloria a las fuerzas armadas
de Ucrania los ataques llegan el mismo
día en que los miembros del g20 se
reunieron para discutir la guerra en
Ucrania en la que múltiples países se
preparan para dar una declaración
conjunta en contra de la invasión rusa
Estados Unidos condenó rotundamente La
ola de ataques y aseguró que solo
servirán para aumentar las
preocupaciones del grupo